[Music]
cardi B isn't holding back I love how he
treats me the rapper stuns on the cover
of Cosmopolitan's April issue and inside
the mag she gets candid about her
decision to stay with her fiance rapper
offset after rumors swirl too that he
was unfaithful quote it's like everybody
is coming down my neck like why are you
not leaving him you have low self-esteem
I don't have low self-esteem I know I
could get any man I want
but I want to work out my with my man
and I don't got to explain why I'm not
your property this is my life and in a
behind-the-scenes video
she dished on their wedding plans people
constantly ask you about the wedding the
wedding the wedding and this is like oh
so it was like it gotta be perfect and
then I'm the woman tool so I want my
wedding to be perfect and beautiful when
et caught up with cardi B in January she
gave us a taste of her Bridal style come
I wouldn't you guys gotta be like oh you
know like them yeah you don't like them
Gypsy Weddings you know how they've been
overdoing it yeah it gotta be overdone
how many dresses yeah you know I need
like a dress they're like big and
they're like you know like a dress that
I could do a split on you never know I
get a look crazy sometimes
you
[Music]